why should there be they have higher
suicide rates that could possibly be one
reason and maybe
all the Privileges
excuse me my brothers are white males so
I don't I don't I'm giving you enough
but I'm saying I'm saying I've had I've
had two brothers that tried to commit
suicide and I'm saying it's not they
didn't try to commit suicide because and
I'm not sorry I don't try to bring in
personal situations I shouldn't do that
but but like it's not because like they
they were thinking oh I have privileges
it's because life can be hard as a man
there's there's a lot of privileges
offered to women that men do not get and
I'm giving you examples but it's like
I'm asking I'm asking you white men and
why they should be gay no no I said I
said this is a privilege that women get
that men don't often
because grants are given to people who
are 18 to to 25. so somebody over that
can they be like oh no they're they're
okay forgiven to people all the time
okay let's take quotas that's across all
ages so I'm giving you specific examples
where women are benefited and men are
not so they're quotas that's at any age
that are given to women that are not
offered to men so I'm saying give me an
example of a privilege that is given to
women that is not given to men outside
of Body Count you can't don't say
sleeping around one double standard that
does not benefit
that does not benefit women
I'm trying to think of one yeah
because I kind of think of like all of
the different disparities that are there
and I could say that that's why let's
answer actually women get three times
the amount of jail sentencing for the
same crime that men do
women can go to the police
oh sorry sorry reverse so yeah yeah men
get three times the amount of sentencing
for the same crime that women do women
can go to the police and say he hit me
and they'll take him to prison is that
true so so I'm asking like where then
all of that gets screwed when you add in
a black person into there
we're talking about gender right now we
are talking about I'm saying it's very
different so everyone can only talk as a
black woman but but it's very different
within the black community if a black
man does something and a black woman
does something it's not the same
treatment is different
let's give a real example so if me and
you was on the street right now me and
you yeah and you slapped me is anybody
gonna react
if I slap you what's gonna happen next
yeah it's a Madness
that's the privilege
though I am a black woman and I could
still get done for that but also there
is the strength issue in there as well
okay when a woman hits a man so we all
agree that men are stronger than women
yeah of course if I hit you and you hit
me the effects are going to be wrong
let's have an example that's the thing
okay because that's the Nuance of it
okay okay let's have an example you go
up and you punch Dwayne The Rock Johnson
in the face he's stronger than you yeah
yeah does anyone feel bad for you when
you get hit back no no why do why do
women get an excuse if a weak man hits a
strong man and gets hit back nobody
feels bad for him why is it that if a
weaker woman hits a stronger man and she
gets hit it against it again so if a
woman hits a man
your argument was strength so you said
you said women women are not as strong
as men yeah but I'm saying so if he goes
up to Dwayne The Rock Johnson Big Jack
dude yes and hits Dwayne first yeah
nobody is going to feel bad for him when
he gets knocked the [__] out because you
shouldn't have messed with him why do
women feel like it's acceptable what
in fact I'll wake up because I'm stupid
from the issue I'm not saying that women
should go around hitting men like
absolutely a man and he hits you back
you hit him first yes but the point is
because he is stronger the penalties are
going to be harder
the whole point was I asked you for a
double standard that doesn't benefit
women outside sleeping around okay so I
get that yeah and the the counter that I
was offering is because there is the
weakness of a woman so when she hits a
man why it's not seen as as impervious
as a man hitting a woman suppose that is
the strength
but there's new ones he looks way
stronger than me right yeah and I he
would I get less time or more time
because he's stronger than me both of
you are men and you both he's stronger
than me it doesn't but
so what are we gonna do so like if if a
man and a woman are fighting what are
they gonna do put them both on the scale
what if she weighs more than me then
what does it mean bro then I knocked her
out
of me it shouldn't that's sexist I think
like it should not I if you if you
should have gender
let me finish let me finish okay I'm
saying gender should not be taken into
consideration if you hit anybody you
should expect to get hit back and the
law should let you say that you were
acting in self-defense but I'm saying
but I'm saying that's not how it is if I
if I hit him and then you knocked me out
how who would the police
no but I'm saying if if it was Dwayne
The Rock Johnson sitting here and he hit
Dwayne The Rock Johnson and he hit him
and then he hit him back and gets
knocked out the police would ask
questions they wouldn't just assume hey
arguments like this is what Amber Heard
can do what she did arguments like that
is what Amber Heard because you caught
me saying that oh I hit you but I didn't
I didn't really hit you did I I'm a girl
so I didn't close my face
but they'll be like I can't hit as hard
as you but it's about the intent that's
what that's what it's about like you
knew you couldn't hit harder than me
when you hit me you know what I mean and
then you got a receipt for your purchase
and now what you say you know what I'm
saying it doesn't matter we're using
extremes to accentuate the point to you
like you can't just say because you're a
woman and you know statistically you're
you're less strong than I am yeah that
if you hit me you didn't intend to hurt
me as much I am given a reason for why
the law but that's that's not what
that's not what it's just because
Society cuddles with certain women and
the law shouldn't be biased it's got
nothing to do with strength No it should
it shouldn't it shouldn't though it
should have lost it whether it does or
not we don't know whether it does
probably say it shouldn't
but that is why it is there but if you
want equality what not you yes again I'm
not talking about you specifically but
feminists want equality why are they not
fighting to speak to feminists about
that but because I'm not about equality
I'm about equity and that's very
different right but the the whole point
is like I'm asking you to name a double
standard that doesn't benefit because
you're not quite getting what you're
talking about I can't name it I don't
think there is that's the truth that's
the truth so I have I have a stat for
you guys give me Harvard so this is you
you would you say Harvard can gather
research effectively it depends what
it's on oh good okay the numbers are
skewed okay Harvard says 70 of abuse is
women against men
why